前回のトゥライムを作った時
失敗してただのエロいローションになったんですけどもー
正直、めっちゃくちゃ悔しかったっす！
やっぱりこう、Dr.はじめとしては
実験で失敗は許されない！っすよ
それから得たモノを使って
確実に僕は成功させるために
ちゃんとレポートも作って
完璧な状態で、今回は
超巨大スライムを確実に、迅速に、完璧に、
作ろうと思います
まずちょっと前回の反省点から説明します
前回の失敗点
皆さんもお気付きの通り、
水が多くなるとどうしてもトロトロになっちゃう
それがスライムが失敗してローションになった原因の一つとして考えられます
そして、二点目。
洗濯のりと水をあまり混ぜてなかった
洗濯のりは一応、
ポリビニールアルコール、PVAって言うやつを
使ってるんですけども
水と洗濯のり、しっかり混ぜないと
部分的に、その混合した水とPVAの物質だけが
そのホウ砂を入れた時に固まっちゃって
スライムのできる所が、こうなんか、点々としちゃって
量も多いですし、完璧なスライムにならないんですよ
こう、部分的にスライム、みたいな。
水にホウ砂を入れても、それはスライムにならないし
そういう訳で、こう、全体的に
「スライム」ってならなかったのも、原因の一つであります
ちなみに「ホウ砂(しゃ)」の事「ホウ砂(さ)」って言ってる人いるけど
正式名称は「ホウ砂(しゃ)」ですから！！
その後、自分でネットとか、こう、いろいろ
スライムについて調べて、わかった事が二点！あります！
一つ目！
スライムの柔らかさが決まります
できるスライムの量が10と仮定した場合、
柔らか目のスライムができます
ま、前回僕は、えーっと
水にが８で、PVAが２ぐらいで作ったんで
あんな事になったんですけれども
普通のトロッとしたスライムができると。
その場合
堅めのスライムができます
今回はちょっと按配(あんばい)を取って
洗濯のり多めの堅めのスライムを作ろうと思います
すんません、ちょっと科学者として
本気、出すんで。
完成したスライムに、その後、僕、結構実は
前回、ホウ砂を入れてたんスよ、完成したスライムに
堅くなんないかなぁと思って。
けど！実質、
水とPVAの割合で、もう
スライムの堅さ、柔らかさは確定するの　で
その後、ホウ砂をどれだけ足しても、変化はありません
以上を踏まえてね、本気でやりますよ！
悪いんで、ちょっと！
理系魂がはしゃいじゃって！
理系じゃんないですけど。
元・理系ですけど！
洗濯のり４本ですよ。
前回、菜箸で混ぜてたんですけど
あれはナメすぎです！！
御玉とかでしっかり混ぜて
混合物をしっかり作っていきます
ホウ砂ですね、余分めに二つ買っておきました。
本気です！
やっぱ、こう、明るい未来の為にね、
赤と黄色でオレンジ色のスライムを作ろうと思います
ガチだぜ！
作戦としては、
空いたボトル２本分に水を入れて、
簡単な割合、
にするんですよ。洗濯のりと水を
トータルの混合物を10として考えると
まぁ、大体、割合的には
水が3.3333……
洗濯のりが6.6666……
なので、ま、大体、6.5：3.5に近い形で
今回はやります！
あ、ヤベ、ヤベ。
PVA、投入完了です。
今、一応、こんな感じです。
で、次に、この２本。
これで量的には４：２になります
ここに水を入れて、もう投入します
ガチだから！
うわ、ヤベ、ヤベ
うぉう、うぉう、うぉう、おー。
ヤベェ、なんだこれ。
ヤバイヤバイ！ヤベ！
うわーーーーー！！
よっし！
色は、あのー、
できてからのお楽しみなんで。
まだ内緒です
ガチ混ぜだよ
ま、ホウ砂は大体でいいんで
大体でいっか。
ちょっとぬるめのお湯を準備しました
なんでぬるめかっていうと
ホウ砂が溶けやすいようにです
大体でいい、大体で。
おっし！じゃ、そろそろぶち入れます！
頼む頼む頼む
これは、なかなか。
頼む！混ざってくれ！！
うぉ！お！ちょっと待って！
教授「え、次は、はじめしゃちょーの論文です
(咳払い)はじめしゃちょー、どうぞ。」
というわけで、
なんとか終わりました。
作る過程は。
じゃ早速、このフィールドに召喚しようと思います
え、けど、もしなんか
ベチャーとかなったらどうしよう。
いや、そいうのはいい！
これが俺の
スライム学の
限界なんですよ
頼むぞ。
床にこぼれたら退居だろ
じゃ、行きます。
大丈夫かな？退居したくないんだけど。
ちょっと待てよ。
ま、いいや！
うおーーー。
これが
俺の
スライムの
ヤベ、ヤベ、ちょっと待って。
ちょっと待って、ヤバイヤバイヤバイ。
ちょっと待って
ちょっと待って、待って、待って！
ちょっと！
ちょっと待って。
ま、ちょっと固まってんすよ。
そっからが見えないな。
ちょっと待って、これどうすればいい？ちょっと待って。
ちょっと待って、ちょっと待って
これ、どう、どう、ちょっと待って。
ちょっと待って。
スライム、やめろ！おい！おい！ちょっと待って！
こぼれるなよ、おい。
ヤバイヤバイ。
ヤバイ！落ちる！
す、すいませんね。
悪い子じゃないんですけど
一応、スライムできましたんで
まあね、科学ってものは
失敗を繰り返して
成功するもんなんすよ
ヤベ、ヤベ
ちょっと待って！なんなの、これ！
なんとか、スライムは
作れるんで
楽しい(笑)
あの…
親に怒られないレベルで
スライム、作ってみてください
ま、成功って感じで、よかったっす。
じゃあな！
頼むぞ
ちゃんと入れよ、スラム…スラ子。
お！これなら帰る！勝手に！
おし、おし、おし、おし、いい子だ、いい子だ。
こうやって家に帰すんすよ。
え？あ！こっちから帰っちゃダメだって！